bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau 7,8 société ce soir nous allons
aborder un sujet qui touche depuis
longtemps déjà les zones rurales et qui
ne cesse de progresser
également dans les villes les déserts
médicaux en ile-de-france pour 100000
habitants il y a en moyenne 125 et un
médecin généraliste
un chiffre en baisse de 19 % en dix ans
alors comment inverser cette tendance
est ce que c'est possible d'ailleurs
pour répondre à ces questions quatre
spécialistes vont m'accompagner
ce soir le docteur catherine à renouer
également maire de chanteloup les vignes
le docteur benoît couderc médecin chef
du pôle activités transversales au
centre hospitalier de meulan les mureaux
le docteur olivier savary vice doyen
responsable de la recherche dans le
département de médecine générale ufr des
sciences de la santé l uv est ce qu est
le docteur charline boissy porte-parole
de réagir regroupement autonome des
généralistes jeunes installés et
remplaçant en ile-de-france bonsoir à
tous les quatre et encore avant de vous
donner la parole quelques chiffres
encore pour bien comprendre l'enjeu de
ces déserts médicaux dans le département
des yvelines par exemple il ya 105
médecins généralistes pour 100 mille
habitants c'est moins donc que la
moyenne régionale à 125 c 21 % de moins
qu'en 2005 et la moyenne d'âge de ces
médecins généralistes et 53 ans ce sont
des données précises de l'ordre national
des médecins
concrètement est-ce qu'il faut être
inquiet de cette situation je vais
commencer avec vous benoît couderc est
ce que c'est un tableau très sombre que
je dresse là est ce que vous êtes
pessimiste ou alors il ya encore des
ondes est pessimiste sur le nombre
puisque effectivement il ya un retard
d'anticipation sur cette baisse après il
faudra faire avec
et donc les objectifs des médecins mais
avec d'autres c'est d'accompagner donc
moi dans le secteur hospitalier il ya eu
déjà tout un travail sur la permanence
des soins
pour qui a relevé entre les services
d'urgence avec la maison médicale de
garde des points fixes de gare donc il
faut absolument effectivement que dans
le cas d'une urgence dans mon programme
et le patient que je voudrais donc
cesser mis en place depuis longtemps
il ya certainement à parfaire la
lisibilité pour le patient mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui le médecin
généraliste installé va répondre
différemment au tout tout de suite
donc effectivement et je qu'on en
reparlera je pense que ça marche parce
qu'effectivement les hôpitaux les
services d'urgences travail où il ya des
relais avec les médecins généralistes
qui assurent la permanence de soins
ambulatoires catherine à renault en plus
d'être maire vous étiez médecin jusqu'en
septembre et votre expérience à vous
c'est vous avez cherché pendant trois
ans et remplaçant qu'on n'avait pas
trouvé est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes
pas si pessimiste que cela finalement il
faut surtout s'adapter
alors je serai victimiste si personne
n'avait compris je pense que à la fois
les pouvoirs publics et puis les
médecins eux mêmes et les jeunes
médecins ceux qui sortent de la fac donc
au préfet ctive manques il y avait sans
doute une deuxième phase dans l'exercice
libéral de la médecine en france et que
nous sommes en train de la bordée ça
fait quelques années que l'on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé sur 7 sur ses déserts
médicaux programmé pour jean veut pour
preuve dans les années 2003 2005
des études avaient été faites pas
seulement dans les lieux de la grande
ruralité mais dans les seconds de ce
qu'on appelle les quartiers sensibles
puisque là c'est lé premier endroit où
les médecins partent n était pas
remplacés et qu'il fallait proposer à la
population une permanence des soins
il ya des moyens qui ont été donnés tous
n'ont pas été réussie il faut en tirer
quelques quelques conclusions
mais je pense que le fait de cette
alarme et de bonheur a fait prendre en
main l'ensemble des sommes des niveaux
des collectivités du coup on proposer
des solutions et l'on proposait avec des
médecins volontaires
je pense que c'est là le fond de la
réussite olivier salary vous vous
partager ce point de vue des
collectivités qui ont conscience de ce
danger là même en ile de france c'est
vrai que c'est étonnant l'île de france
on se dit la première région de france
il n'y a pas forcément de manque de
médecins et on voit dans les chiffres
qu'on est en dessous de la moyenne
nationale en ile de france et surtout
dans les yvelines
oui je
partage globalement ce qui a été dit je
suis peut-être un tout petit peu moins
alarmiste sur les camps dire le nombre
de médecins au niveau global au niveau
national en fait on n'a jamais eu autant
de médecins en france mais effectivement
le problème pas tellement un problème de
nombre
parce que si c'est un problème de nombre
la réponse ce serait d'augmenter le
numerus clausus de la première année et
à ce moment là les problèmes seraient
résolus
on est à plus de 200 mille médecins
enfin autour de 200 mm son actif alors
qu'à 35 ans on était plutôt autour de
110 milles mais le problème c'est un
problème de répartition et de choix de
spécialités et donc effectivement on a
pour donner un exemple le trivial plus
de dermatologues en paca que dans
l'ensemble du royaume uni donc ce qui
interroge et effectivement vous l'avais
dit en particulier les médecins
généralistes mais d'autres spécialités
un petit peu maintenant aussi commencent
à manquer cruellement et en particulier
dans les yvelines parce que c'est ce qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui
donc l'idée c'est de comment réussir à
donner envie aux jeunes confrères
de s'installer dans des zones où on
manque de médecins et comment leur
donner envie de faire des spécialités
dont on manque cruellement et en
particulier la médecine générale on voit
répondre à cette question du comment on
finit ce premier tour de table avec vous
charline boissy vous qui représentez
finalement les jeunes médecins pourquoi
ne veulent t'ils plus installé on va
dire mise à part en bord de mer ou là où
il ya du soleil vous provoque un petit
point mais pourquoi alors non il
s'installe pas que en bord de mer et que
là où il ya du soleil la preuve en est
que depuis quelques années des
territoires vraiment haut pour
lesquelles on a vraiment tiré la
sonnette d alarme et qui ont réagi henri
notamment comme vous le disiez en se
posant la question de comment avoir des
maîtres de stage comment comment faire
connaître leur région je pense par
exemple la région de clermont-ferrand
qui a vu son nombre d'installations
rural augmenté donc ses preuves qu'il ya
quand même des choses qui sont possibles
après le nombre de médecins
effectivement jamais été aussi important
mais il ya des problématiques donc
olivier a rappelé mais les jeunes ne
sais pas qui ne veulent pas s'installer
qui ne veulent pas s'installer comme
leurs aînés ne veulent pas globalement
travaillé comme leurs aînés sans vouloir
faire de cas pas que le nombre d'heures
il ya un nombre d'heures effectivement
on peut pas reprocher à un médecin et
peu importe ça peu importe son âge parce
que je pense que là pour le coup c'est
pas du tout générationnel ça concerne
tout le monde quand la population est à
35 heures ou en tout cas pas plus de
reprocher un médecin ne pas pouvoir vous
voir pas vouloir faire plus que 50
heures ça paraît pas si aberrant que ça
en tout cas
donc ça c'est la première chose mais
surtout les médecins ils veulent
travailler ensemble ils veulent
travailler en groupe mais pas que entre
médecins ils veulent s'organiser sur le
territoire pourra prendre en charge la
population donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un
travail qui est en tout cas dans le soin
des jeunes médecins un travail
une envie de travailler avec les
infirmiers les kinés les pharmaciens les
professionnels de proximité les
professionnels de premier recours et
après finalement que ce soit du libéral
ou du salariat ou peu importe quoi c'est
pas la question la question c'est
vraiment de comment est ce qu'on a envie
de travailler et on n'a pas envie de
travailler seul dans un cabinet à faire
de l'acte ça c'est certain
donc il ya vraiment quelque chose à
faire et en plus c'est cet enjeu la
correspond aussi à l'enjeu actuel de la
population c'est qu'on a des patients
qui sont plus en plus âgés plus en plus
polypathologiques on a de plus en plus
une envie de faire de la prévention de
faire du dépistage et ça ça peut plus
résoudre juste par un pain de
consultation à l'acte à 15h15
olivier salle rit je reviens vers vous
par rapport à quelque chose qui m'a
plutôt choqués on parle souvent c'est
vrai il ya beaucoup d'étudiants qui
veulent faire médecine beaucoup d'échecs
et on parle de plus en plus dans
l'actualité de déserts médicaux comment
comment on peut comprendre ce paradoxe
entre les élèves qui sont nombreux à
vouloir faire ça et puis les déserts
médicaux qui ne cessent de type nature
ce pays a un problème aussi au niveau de
la formation on vous le disiez la
première année et elle produire ou
faut-il assouplir les règles
la première année a été même si elle
reste difficile nettement assoupli
depuis quelques années on a à peu près
doublé le nombre d'étudiants accepté en
2e année sur ces dernières années ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs au besoin parce
qu'il va y avoir un départ à la retraite
assez massif des confrères et donc c'est
normal qu'ils aient eu une augmentation
de ce nombre après aller au delà
encore une fois le problème n'est
sûrement pas une question de nombre
global c'est plus une question de
répartition
donc c'est je reviens sur ce que ce
qu'on disait comment comment réussir à
donner envie aux jeunes médecins d'aller
s'installer là on a besoin d'eux et dans
les spécialités on a le plus besoin
d'eux en termes de santé publique
alors si c'est ça dont je commence
justement on va on va tenter de répondre
à la question avec vous docteur coubert
comment on fait pour résoudre ce
problème par exemple
le gouvernement a lancé un pacte
territoire santé en 2012 avec des
incitations financières est ce que ça
c'est un bon moyen de donner envie aux
jeunes de s'installer là où il est moins
de médecins pacte le territoire santé je
le serai peut-être plus compétents que
moi mais je voulais que ce qu'on fait il
ya déjà dans la vision hospitalière
cette réforme doit santé qui concerne
aussi d'autres secteurs mais qui met en
place des groupements ce territoire dans
les yvelines et plus particulièrement en
or très rapidement puisque pour le 1er
juillet doit rendre copie au directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé
avec ce qui est intéressant un projet
médical partagé
donc il ya déjà il faut qu'il y ait une
réflexion effectivement sur les filières
pour pas qu'ils aient redondances entre
les établissements de santé
et effectivement dans ce projet musical
santé on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'avenir c'est de s'ouvrir mais de
travailler avec ce qu'on appelle la
ville pour faire réseau ville hôpital
mais je suis assez d'accord il ya plus
libérale fonctionnaires d'un côté c'est
donc une notion de territoire de santé
au pacte santé juge alors voilà la
parole vous est donné castanet arnaud
sur ce cette incitation financière est
ce que c'est ça un bon moyen pour pour
donner envie aux jeunes de s'installer
je ne crois pas qu incitations
financières ni ni limites financières en
fin de compte solution contrainte soit
une solution
je crois qu'il faut vraiment se poser
tous ensemble la question d'avoir on est
en train de redéfinir ce qui est la
médecine tels que les patients
l'imaginent encore et il faut peut-être
se poser la question de ce que c'est
devenu un service au public
et comment exerçons nous ensemble un
service au public avec la foi dans sa
frange libérale qui va perdurer sans
doute un temps dans sa frange
hospitalière et dans un dans une dans
une permanence des soins parce que le
patient a besoin de soins qui n'est pas
due soit en permanence
il faut peut-être se poser la question
de d'une nouvelle définition d'une
évolution alors
les contraintes et les incitations moi
j'y crois très peu je crois que chacun
dans son rôle a nécessité à prendre en
charge je vais vous donner un exemple
que les médecins s'approprient cette
nouvelle façon d'exercer d'exercer en
groupe et disent leur volonté l'ol leur
volonté de temps d'exercice mais aussi
de conditions d'exercice de relations
partenariales qu'il le dise il nous faut
tous l'entendre mais nous à tous les
niveaux de la cote des collectivités
locales que ce sont les villes qui ne
doivent pas être les seuls porteurs de
dispositifs mais aussi le département
qui s'implique beaucoup dans ce sens est
dans cet exercice là parce que on sent
qu'il ya vraiment une vraie demande à la
fois des élus mais aussi des habitants
comment est ce qu'on peut comprendre les
freins pour dans nos compétences essayer
de les lever ou d'aider à les lever
ça ne peut se faire qu'avec une volonté
très partenariale celui qui a les moyens
éventuellement de l'investissement celui
qui a lu moyens d'aidé au fonctionnement
mais mais derrière il ya qui veut
travailler en partenariat et qui veut
sur un territoire créer des voix une
vraie offre de soins qui sera sans doute
pas celle qu'on a imaginé qu'on a vécu
dans les années 50 qui sera une autre
forme
je serre les voici sur cet argument que
sur lequel j'insiste sur l'incitation
financière que c'est l'un des points
majeurs du pacte territoire santé c'est
l'incitation financière vous synovite ne
sait pas forcément là je me dirai je me
dirai peut-être un petit peu dans les
solutions qui ont été proposées par les
packs directeur santé via mail
et puis un deuxième il ya le contrat le
pt mj praticiens territoriale de
médecine générale
plus que de sécuriser le début
d'exercice en permettant d'assurer un
revenu aux médecins ces contrats
permettent aussi une prévoyance
notamment aux femmes aux jeunes femmes
qui peuvent être en situation de
grossesse et donc ça permet quand même
de sécuriser cette ce début d'exercice
et l'exercice du jeune
je pars en pensant notamment la
maternité via ce contrat donc c'est pas
vraiment que du financier c'est aussi
quelque chose qui permet de rassurer un
peu on a tendance à dire que le libéral
fait peur est ce que vraiment libéral
fait peur je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas il ya très clairement et célèbres
bon nombre des jeunes le dise le côté le
côté entreprises libérales le côté
absences de prévoyance absence de
sécurité qui a tendance à faire peur
donc c'est plutôt vers ça peut-être
qu'il faut qu'il faut chercher puis le
fait d'être tout seul c'est aussi
quelque chose qui peut qui peut
inquiéter alors par contre sur le
coercitif c'est évident que et s'il ya
beaucoup de travaux qu'il montre ça ne
peut pas fonctionner vous l'avez évoqué
aujourd'hui on pour faire face à cette
pénurie de médecins beaucoup de
collectivités ont recours aux maisons de
santé un lieu unique où est rassemblée
plusieurs spécialistes ça permet d'être
plus attractif de ne pas être seul dans
son cabinet on en parlait à saint
quentin en yvelines par exemple la ville
de coignières dispose d'une maison de
santé
bientôt guyancourt également en 2010 est
ensuite ce sera à montigny le bretonneux
l'agglomération soutient ces maisons de
santé
à ce propos écoutez dominique catelin
conseillère communautaire déléguée à
l'action sociale et à la santé nous
avons commencé une étude sur les 12 que
nous et qui va bientôt voir le jour elle
va apparaître je prépare mes collègues
actuellement il y a dans certaines
communes ont des manques de médecins
généralistes au niveau des passions de
rencontrer tous les tous types de
médecins et ça c'est vraiment pour moi
un avantage surtout notre commune où
quand on écoute les spécialistes ce type
d'émission qu'on est en train de le
faire ça qu on entend beaucoup cesser
ces maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
comme la solution parfaite idéal qui va
régler tous les problèmes est ce que
vous partagez ce point de vue est ce que
c'est exagéré
oui c'est sûrement une des solutions je
vous rejoins quand vous dites qu'il faut
que la solution soit partagée entre le
politique le médecin la demande
évidemment de la population il faut que
les choses soient concertés
je veux juste pour revenir une seconde
sur ce qui était dit avant là aussi je
rejoins ce qui a été dit sur le fait que
les mesures coercitives ont pas
tellement fait preuve de leur efficacité
et par l'histoire aussi de la médecine
en france ça semble compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre et par contre je me lance un
tout petit peu le bilan négatif on va
dire des incitatifs
parce que finalement il ya donc
effectivement le ptm j'ai le praticien
territoriale de médecine générale
donc il ya eu à peu près 500 signatures
depuis 2000 faim depuis que ça a été mis
en place en 2013 jusqu'en 2015 et il ya
le contrat d'engagement de service
public où c'est un étudiant en médecine
qui va recevoir une bourse de l'ordre de
1200 euros par mois donc c'est un
engagement assez conséquent finalement
de l'état et qui s'engagent à
s'installer en zone déficitaire
autant de temps au minimum que ce qu'il
a reçu la bourse
donc si la reçois je suis en 3e année
médecine et qui fait ces temps de
d'études et bien il va au moins
s'installer c'est en zone d est à la fac
vous voyez les étudiants intéressés par
ce processus là voilà c'est alors c'est
un processus qui avait relativement
mauvaise presse au début parce que vous
savez on a l'impression d'acheter un peu
le web puis parce qu'on est français on
n'est toujours méfiant quand il ya une
nouveauté on va peut-être se faire avoir
on en reparle rond pourra plus choisir
on pourra y voilà et en fait il s'avère
que c'est un dispositif assez souple et
ses problèmes en pour ça aussi que c'est
intéressant qui contraint pas le médecin
de s'installer toujours pendant les sept
ans où les huit ans où les cinq ans dans
la même commune au même endroit
simplement il
ils s'engagent à s'installer en zone
déficitaire mais s'ils déménagent il
peut contacter une nouvelle ars et
s'installer dans une autre zone qui en a
besoin et donc c'est un dispositif
finalement assez souple qui avait pas
excellent de presse et toutes premières
années et on voit bien que les
signatures sont en train d'augmenter de
manière exponentielle mais en tout cas
assez conséquente et on a aujourd'hui
donc 1320 à peu près signature au niveau
national et en ile-de-france 213 je
passe chiffres exacts dans les yvelines
mais plus de 200 en ile de france donc
ça contribue à son échelle mais à lutter
contre cette désertification
après dans les autres mesures vous avez
parlé de la maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle évidemment que ça
fait partie des choses qui vont donner
envie aux médecins d'aller s'installer
c'est celle qui est mise souvent en
avant en tout cas dans les médias dans
la mauvaise bien sûr la mesure numéro a
bien sûr et ça fait partie effectivement
de ces solutions
je vais essayer tout le monde s'exprimer
sur ce sujet à un autre point qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur
c'est le contact que peuvent avoir les
étudiants en médecine avec des médecins
déjà installés dans ces zones là et donc
il me semble important de développer des
terrains de stage des maîtres de stage
universitaire qui vont accueillir
pendant alors trois mois six mois en
fonction du niveau d'études des
étudiants
l'inter nll externe à son cabinet et
c'est comme ça que les liens se créent
et c'est comme ça qu'on trouve un
remplaçant quelqu'un qui va reprendre le
cabinet plus tard et c'est comme ça
aussi qu'on donne envie aux gens de
faire cette médecine qui lorsqu'elle
n'est jamais vue forcément on a rarement
envie de faire ce qu'on connaît pas
benoît couderc sur ces maisons de santé
sont les formes durables taupe à l'irak
non je dis je suis fâché dans ma vie
professionnelle je ne crois pas aux
miracles mais les je crois que ce qu'on
dit là c'est effectivement on voit bien
c'est une ouverture donc ville hôpital
je vais déjà dit mais c'est une
ouverture avec les autres professionnels
de santé
l'intérêt de ces maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires et d'autres c'est un
exercice effectivement médecins il faut
pas oublier parce qu'on parle des
déserts nsa médicaux je pense que le
médecin généraliste est effectivement le
ciblées mais n'oublions pas d'abord
d'autres spécialités
les pédiatres qui sont raréfiés et tous
et il ya des spécialités et aussi les
professions dites paramédical mais les
kinés on a il faut faire attention donc
l'intérêt de ces maisons horlogères
c'est de se retrouver effectivement dans
c'est plus intéressant c'est plus
rassurant journée et tous les intérêts
non mais c'est bon tu as eu ton bien
c'est ce qu'on trouve à l'hôpital qui
reste et je comprends bien
qu'aujourd'hui le collègue médecin
généraliste c'est de pouvoir échanger
discuter des dossiers de discuter en
conversation c'est plus facile que même
si les hôpitaux doivent encore
s'améliorer mais vous réponds plus
facilement une
dans un territoire donné si on connaît
les médecins généralistes sur l'hôpital
de meaux leur numéro mais sur les
hôpitaux on connaît la soixantaine de
médecins ils ont leurs habitudes et il
faut absolument répondre mais il faut
ces maisons de santé regroupement
effectivement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
l'exercice sera à peu et des facilités
est un bien grand mot un peu aider s'ils
ne sont pas tous seuls et s'ils se
sentent soutenus ne doivent pas porter à
eux seuls justement ce point de déserts
médicaux de compte je pense qu'on peut
pas et c'est ça qui fait peur c'est à
l'hôpital ces voix là le côté assimilés
fonctionnaires
j'ai je n'aurais pas grossesse mois
particulièrement mais une femme un congé
maternité
on va la remplacer il ya aussi beaucoup
de postes vacants dans les hôpitaux mais
le service va continuer une organisation
plus facile parce qu'on est plusieurs
en ville c'est beaucoup plus difficile
j'ai voilà c'est donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment relais moi je crois
beaucoup à la géo territoire est cette
rentrée quatre scénarios soit cette
question des maisons de santé
alors si c'est effectivement ce que je
crois à l'exercice à venir
en tout cas le choix de l'exercice à
venir chez les médecins et paramédicaux
voir d'autres professions parce qu'on
peut ouvrir ce sont des projets qui sont
lourds à porter c'est ce sont des 1500
pour les communes n'ont pas du tout pour
les médecins humaine
si ce sont des médecins qui sont déjà
installés c'est à la fois lourd parce
que c'est une autre compétence un qui
n'est pas une compétence médicale
c'est lourd c'est très chronophage et
c'est là je pense que les collectivités
à la fois les collectivités locales et
le département doit doit être dans
l'aide à maîtrise d'ouvragé parce que
parce que c'est pas le médecin s'est pas
même les médecins il faut qu'il porte un
projet faut qu'ils aient envie de
travailler ensemble
il faut qu'ils se projettent longtemps
dans l'avenir mais faire ce qui est le
dur le l'ensemble du dossier l'ensemble
du portage de projets je pense que c'est
bien que si les pouvoirs publics
lance l'initiative les médecins vont
suivre non je pense que si les médecins
ont envie d'un projet les pouvoirs
publics doivent suivre d'accord c'est le
votre point de vue aussi charlebois s'il
faut pas mélanger c'est pas une commune
qui dit je veux faire une maison de
santé puis après appel les médecins les
médecins viendront pas ça doit être
vraiment des professionnels qui sont
déjà plus ou moins ancré sur le
territoire ou qui du moins ont une
appétence avec pour ce territoire parce
qu'ils sont venus quand il était
étudiant parce qu'ils ont remplacés et
qui ont envie de s'engager auprès de
cette population là et qu'ils puissent
être accompagnés
est-ce que c'est dans une maison de
santé est ce que c'est dans un climat
une coupe est-ce que c'est dans un
centre de santé
j'ai presque envie de dire peu importe
c'est vrai que malgré tout la maison de
santé peut paraître être quelque chose
d'assez lourd en terme en termes
notamment administratifs organisationnel
il faut savoir que nous on est on est
formés dans nos études globalement au
colloque singulier un patient et médecin
et puis après des indications pour
adresser ou pour pas adressés la
problématique de travailler ensemble
sans hiérarchie dans une maison de santé
ça peut être aussi quelque chose qui
peut être problématique pour pour les
pour les professionnels qui ne
correspond pas forcément à tous l'idée
c'est vraiment de chercher avec les
professionnels en fonction de leurs
souhaits leurs envies de faire de la
médecine et de de soigner la population
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
s'organiser et c'est vrai que là il ya
il n'y a pas la solution miracle c'est
la meilleure solution c'est peut-être
celle qui est l écoute de l'ensemble des
professionnels d'un territoire et donc
c'est peut-être ça un an je sais que les
pouvoirs publics les maires peuvent
mettre en contact et provoquer le
provoquer la rencontre et la discussion
entre les professionnels d'un même
territoire
je voudrais avoir votre avis maintenant
sur la télémédecine c'est vrai en 2016
savez quelque chose aussi qui semble se
développer
peut-être plus de sons mais qui se met
en place
est ce que vous êtes favorable certains
la critique certains sont pour
quel est votre point de vue à vous je
suis très favorable après comme tout
effectivement faut des règles où il ya
des contraintes il faut cette vidéo dans
la dans le dialogue et tous
effectivement alors en médecine
d'urgence on a commencé avec la
neurochirurgie plutôt de transférer le
malade on a commencé à transférer des
images et puis à se parler
gentil avec le neurochirurgien on le
fait beaucoup et ça avait des progrès
sur l'accident vasculaire cérébral
donc il ya des exemples que je suis plus
sur les urgences de mon ancienne
fonction mais aujourd'hui ma nouvelle en
dermatologie et on commence alors sa
demande effectivement la télémédecine là
où il faut faire attention c'est il faut
quand même en médecine savoir à qui je
m'adresse et pourquoi je m'adresse donc
il ya quand même les limites c'est pas
juste un transfert de dossiers jugés
dans ma partie hospitalière je m'occupe
d'évaluation des pratiques
professionnelles ou des fois je trouvais
sur dossiers souvent pas le malade c'est
pas la même chose
donc attention à la télémédecine ya
quand même un échange et c'est ça ma
jeremic maison il faut développer il
faut utiliser pour moi c'est outil plus
moderne parler je serai plus large du
système d'information le il faut
absolument qu entre les hôpitaux et les
médecins généralistes on améliore nos
systèmes d'information donc aider
probablement là par les pouvoirs publics
sur ce qu'on appelle le dossier médical
partagé pour aider pour qu'ils aient
moins de redondance sur les examens pour
qu'ils aient un échange
voilà comment on parle de tracasseries
en dérange on appelle souvent s'appelle
entre nous mais des fois si on pouvait
être aidé un peu plus par les systèmes
d'information et dont la télémédecine
qui est un outil mais attention avec
certaines règles il faut pas les
applications aussi aujourd'hui qui
existent pour rentrer en contact avec un
médecin spécialiste ça peut permettre
d'éviter des déplacements parfois un peu
exagéré on va dire si on a juste
quelques symptômes pas forcément très
très grave
on pourrait demander voilà j'ai ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous en pensez
quoi
je suis sans marie pascale et médecine
c'est une question compliquée c'est une
question compliquée je pense
qu'effectivement
effectivement on vit avec notre temps et
c'est un potentiel formidable sur lequel
on va pouvoir probablement progresser
répondre en partie pour l'un d'eux
désertification et problement tous
améliorés c'est aussi potentiellement
voilà dans son aspect le plus
caricatural un danger parce qu'on voit
bien et je vais pas citer le livre mais
je le délire actuelle du médecin qui va
dans son espèce de boîte de de
photomaton là et curés sont
diagnostiqués et tout ce qui va avec
je dire on fera pas sans lien humain et
on fera pas sans le colloque dont vous
avez parlé entre le médecin et son
patient c'est quand même le fondement de
la médecine et ses patients c'est à dire
ses antécédents et la relation est
extrêmement importante donc je crois pas
en la télémédecine magique qui réglera
tout est parti d'un ordinateur
mais effectivement bien encadré bien
réfléchir et ça peut aider
comme je suis parti manger le défaut
d'être hospitalisé il ya qu'eux mêmes et
ce à la médecine ça reste avant tout je
refais l'apparence d'accès aux soins il
ya quand même un échange avec un patient
qui doit être là je parlais de la
télémédecine pour justement sur
certaines spécialités mais avec des
spécialistes que je connais ou qu'ils me
reconnaissent en disant voilà alors
c'est la dernière théologique et c'est
pas voilà dans une commune ya pourtant
de fond ça et c'est le cas un agent
administratif qui prend contact ne
l'attendait bien d'accord dans la
médecine
un échange qui braveront charlène voici
sur la télémédecine puis vous aurez vous
conclurez catherine ahronot ben je vous
rejoins sur le fait que télémédecine
savez avec système d'information c'est
certain et se poser la question de
comment communiquer comme entre
communiquer les informations et là on
est encore dans une limite de la
médecine libérale puisqu'on n'est plus
vraiment qu'on s'adresse à un médecin
que hospital et le médecin qui dans son
cabinet on est on est plus du tout dans
de l'acte et ça fait partie des choses
qui qui à mon avis freine un peu
l'évolution de l'évolution de ce que
pourrait être notre exercice autrement
après on c'est évident que c'est des
choses il faut qu'on les accompagne il
faut pas qu'on les tubistes donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut être acteur de et
proposer des choses en ce sens à votre
conclure très rapidement sur la crise et
des moyens de transport d'informations
donc on pourrait parler aussi de moyen
de transport c'est à dire que là où les
médecins ce n'est pas aux médecins de
prendre en charge ces les moyens du
transfert d'informations c'est les
moyens du transport des patients à
l'offre dans le cadre de la prévention
dans le cadre du soin je crois qu'à un
moment donné on ne chaque territoire
aussi petit soit il n'aura ne pourra pas
disposer d'un certain nombre de médecins
mais il faut qu'à un moment donné ils
ont utilisé la possibilité d'avoir du
soin à proximité dans une proximité
qu'on peut tout ce dont on peut tous se
voir les limites donc à nous de nous
emparer d des moyens mis à disposition
des médecins
merci pour la rapidité de votre réponse
merci à vous quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci pour vos réponses
cette émission est à retrouver en
podcast sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous